each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available thanks so much for coming my
name is Amy Draves and I'm delighted to
welcome Jim DWI to the Microsoft
research visiting speaker series he'll
be discussing his book more awesome than
money in which he focuses on the four
individuals that created the open-
source social media site
diaspora Jim is a Pulitzer prizewinning
reporter and he writes the column about
New York in the New York Times and has
written or co-written six books
including 102 minutes 2 seconds under
the world and actual innocence he
appeared in Ken Burns's documentary
Central Park 5 and was portrayed on
Broadway in last year
Norah Efron play lucky guy with Tom
Hanks please join me and giving him a
very warm
welcome a couple of years ago I this has
nothing to do with my talk but a couple
years ago I I was
a briefly a visiting professor at
Princeton and I was working at the Times
then as I am now
and they all were kind of nice to me
down there they knew I wasn't going to
be in their hair too long there for a
semester but they the um remember the
chairman of the humanities Council which
was where I was
teaching came up to me and say you know
you know people here love the New York
Times you know what they say they say
the times is really great in everything
except my field
so I am now here in your field and I um
am quite conscious of uh all the great
and deep work that you guys do and and
I'm I'm appreciative of it
and I just want to say that sometimes
I if I do seem like I I know my ass from
my elbow it's only an act but I'm gonna
do my best okay so
it's February
2010 One Last Time Dan grippy checked
updates from friends then he found his
way to the account settings on his
Facebook page buried several layers deep
was the Box Dan a senior at NYU in New
York was looking for delete account was
he
sure Dan clicked his affirmation
okay then the account would be
deactivated but not actually deleted for
two more weeks any activity by him
during that time logging in checking on
Friends the least flicker of digital
life would be interpreted by Facebook as
a sign that he had changed his mind and
really didn't want to shut it down this
was all boiler plate delivered to anyone
who declared an intention to leave the
flock the next
message was from Facebook was tailored
for Dan
grippy
Dan your friends are going to miss you
it said Dan had about 400 friends on
Facebook a number of them people he had
never spoken with In the
Flesh or for that matter online someone
who knew someone would send a friend
request he'd say yes and that would be
the end of it no
loss but there were others real buds
from high school people he cared about
in college family members authentic
friends their pictures were the ones
appearing on the
screen it was a simple matter for the
Facebook servers to figure out who
profile he had checked on out with whom
he had exchanged messages even people
who were in the same
picture Facebook kept records of what he
cared about knowing who and what Dan
wanted in his life life knowing more
than Dan himself consciously knew was
Facebook's business it sold that
knowledge Daniel Facebook pleaded
wouldn't you want to stay in touch with
these
people they were hostages Facebook was
transforming his attempt to quit the
network into a betrayal of his fondness
for
them
manipulation he clicked the delete
button in the
that same winter Dan and uh three other
friends all together four talented young
nerds with times on their hands decided
that they should bring an end to
Facebook's Monopoly on social
networking
and they thought with the right
software no one would need to S
surrender everything to big companies
like Facebook P people could connect to
friends and network of friends without
going through the servers of Facebook
Inc it was a simple notion of vast
disruption and to Dan and to his three
friends in the computer Club at
NYU Ilia
zisy Max
salsburg uh and Raphael sofair they
thought it would be a fun way to spend
the
summer so in the months before then they
spent uh nearly every conscious minute
in a computer clubroom at myu working on
their upstart social network
project they called it
diaspora and if you double click to edit
you can fix that for me
um they set out to create what I guess
would in essence be uh a peer-to-peer
social network they called it
distributed social networking
I don't think I need to explain to
people in this room the complexity of
that possibility or the sort of
Simplicity of the idea behind
it the four guys who were in on this
project uh Raphael Max Dan and Ilia of
course were each different
personalities uh
Raphael was a neuroscience major kind of
a
math uh Prodigy of his in his own right
a very cool calm collected guy from
paloalto California his father had been
a counselor to the state department
during the first George Bush and Ronald
Reagan Era and uh a very level-headed
young man Max salsberg was a kind of
aspiring CEO he had been
going through uh College without a lot
of Joy until he discovered the computer
club and uh Kindred Spirits people who
didn't mind getting uh getting their
arms deep into code late in the
night Dan grippy who was uh their kind
of glammer figure he was a um a master
designer he was a uh a musician and uh
he worked as a model for a
while and uh Ilia
zamiri who was a Russian
imigra at age 18 he was taking PhD level
math
classes he was uh an extreme whoops
let's see
here get back
to this thing here um he was a
um
competitive swing dancer he was a kite
glider he was a dumpster diver a juggler
and uh spoke several languages and
altogether a very Charming delightful
guy the four of them thought it would be
a great idea for them to head out
onto uh Max's mother's basement for the
summer and hack away at this
project
they didn't really think that anybody
else actually cared about it that
much but they didn't want to leech off
of their parents for the summer they
were the youngest of them rafie was 19
and Max was 22 and he and Dan were about
to graduate and they didn't really feel
like they should stick their hands out
so they thought maybe we can raise
$10,000 on Kickstarter which was then a
brand new
platform
and they debated whether this was
feasible or not and then they put
together a a very slap happppy video and
made their pitch on Kickstarter they
said by the end of the summer they would
have built a code base that other
hackers could then work on they would
make it public and free and anybody who
wanted to could could work on the DI
they call their project diaspora because
uh it means distrib one of the meanings
of it is distributed comes from the
Greek spreading seeds far and wide and
of course it's known for people who have
left their homelands particularly uh the
ancient Jews but also other people since
then so but they called their project
diaspora and they thought anyone who
wanted to pitch in could help them on
the code so they put up this um Appeal
on
Kickstarter
and within a couple of days they had
gotten uh6 or $7,000 and the word
started to spread a little bit they got
$8,000 and then they got
$10,000 and they had hit their
goal the money didn't stop
coming they were up to about
$25,000 when I heard about
it and uh the way I heard about it is a
bit of a Shaggy Dog tail but I think I
might as well pass along here in 2004 my
my eldest daughter was going to college
starting college and uh she and her
roommate got hold of this brand new
thing called Facebook it was the first
semester that Facebook was widely
distributed to schools outside of the
ivy
league
and it was so compelling and attractive
to them that they spent all their time
on it and uh eventually when midterms
were coming realized they would never
get any studying done if they still were
mainlining Facebook all the time so they
swapped passwords with each
other so that my daughter Mora would
have her roommate Katie's password for
all but 15 minutes of the day and vice
versa so they
could ease off of Facebook at least
through midterms
they happen to mention this to my wife
who MOA happened to tell my wife and she
was then doing her uh finishing her
master's work in computer science and uh
was thinking about what her dissertation
project should be and she thought maybe
I'll do something on privacy Management
in Myspace in Facebook and so she became
one of the early scholars in that
area and indeed wrote her dis about it
and uh some years later heard about
these four guys at myyu who were raising
uh a lot of money on Kickstarter I had
never heard of
Kickstarter um and they were doing quite
well and it so happened that it was one
of these
moments when uh as you know Facebook has
a
genius for really getting people Furious
and uh they happened to be in the midst
of one of those moments and I'm just
going to read a little section about
that for you
now uh what is the thing they have every
year the
f8 the F something they have some big
conference every year down in San
Francisco where all the developers come
in
and uh this particular year 2010 when
the diaspora boys went up on
Kickstarter
Mark Zuckerberg said to the crab we
think that what we have to show you
today will be the most transformative
thing that we've ever done for the
web that day Zuckerberg and his chief
technical officer Brett Taylor ran
through a series of changes that would
give Facebook a presence on other
websites with like buttons when clicked
these like buttons would alert the
users's friends and anyone else who
viewed their Facebook pages of their
interest what they have been looking at
and presumably thinking about the likes
were a form of currency that Facebook of
course would negotiate into advertising
dollars when other changes were added in
including the ability to watch what
people were reading away from the
Facebook site what Zuckerberg and his
backers were proposing was nothing less
than becoming the toll booth and gateway
to the whole
internet by following the interest of
its users across cyberspace Facebook
would plant its flag and die on every
corner of the
web what Facebook and Zuckerberg and
Brett Taylor saw as a great expansion of
human connectedness others saw as a
silken trap from which there would be no
escape this is really a significant step
for Facebook said Taylor for years we've
been saying it's an open
platform but for now but now for the
first time the likes and interests of my
Facebook profile linked to place places
that are not on
facebook.com my identity is not just
defined by things on Facebook it's
defined by things all over the web this
may have been seen as an unalloyed giant
step forward to Zuckerberg Taylor and
others in the bubble of Facebook's
headquarters outside the reaction was
brutal the toughest because the non-tech
Press relied on it to render the changes
into non-geek speak was wired which ran
a major essay that became the most R
story on its website for a
month and uh I only need mention the
headline was Facebook has gone Rogue and
they called for a distributed public uh
excuse me a distributed a distributed
social
network and just around that same time a
Columbia Professor studied Facebook
users asking their intentions and
beliefs about their control of the
privacy settings then he compared it
with their actual settings now these
were Advanced students at Columbia right
he found that 90% were sharing material
that they had had intended to keep
private and a perfect 100% were not
achieving their privacy
goals
so one consequence of this
uproar was
that attention to Diaspora which U I
gave it some with a column in the
times
uh exploded more than 6,000 people from
18 countries pitched in
$200,000 20 times what they had
initially s and then a half million
others joined a waiting list for
invitations four guys hanging around a
little room at NYU suddenly found
themselves handed a global
commission to rebottle the genie of
personal
privacy for a time they were the faces
of a revolution against the settled
digital
order now what drove these young men out
to uh what what inspired them was a the
difficulty of the problem and also the
need for it they had attended Talks by
uh Ean moglin who many of you may know
is a a a um free software Advocate and
uh he's a lawyer and historian a
technologist and uh they had become come
convinced as I believe uh others had
that the web was reaching a kind of a
state of social
emergency
and since we have a couple of seconds
here are are any of you folks familiar
with uh the Firefox tool
light um well I'll tell I'll get the
name of it for you in a second let's
just look at a couple of U things
here
to demonstrate how
quickly things get linked
up what I'm on Facebook how did that
happen and
uh okay so there's a bank and there's
the cabinet company where I'm looking at
some cabinets
for uh my kitchen and Facebook and the
New York Times
and this thing here is called
U light
beam and what it shows I don't know if
you've had a chance to see this thing
before is all of the tracking that go
whoops that goes on with each of the
sites that you open up so when the times
opened
up sure that that's legible but it says
bizor graphics.com I don't know who they
are uh there's multiple others each of
these little advertising Moet ads
company um Zilla company and so forth
and some of them connect out Google
syndication connects out to
2mdn.net
which then links over to
chase.com so if we open up a couple of
more things we'll see some um some other
great things let's see let's try the New
York post.com I'm not sure that's a big
paper out here in Seattle but we get a
lot of it in New York and we'll go to
ESPN and let's take a look again at uh
light
beam and uh it's essentially
metastasizing before our eyes Okay more
and more links are spreading out further
and further
what these four guys with this
interesting summer
planned they were in the midst of not
just a discussion about rebuilding a
social network but I think they were
involved with discussions about the open
web our surveillance economy free
societies and from their perspective
also
love joy uis bravery and uh death
actually as well
so they went out to
um California and were set up at a place
called pivotal labs they also uh which
does a lot of contract work they invited
them out host them there they became
actually quite popular among uh many of
the leading figures in
uh in in in in the web they were Tim
burner's Lee who they actually hadn't
even heard of was a a fan of theirs Mark
Zuckerberg actually gave ,000 towards
their
Kickstarter
um and some of the biggest names in
Venture Capital were also interested in
what they were doing and so for the next
three months they were worked pretty
much around the clock to build the
diaspora
framework and uh they released that in
September
2015 now one of the issues with diaspora
is like how many people are using it
right but diaspora is meant to
be passed along and used by individuals
it's very much like WordPress you
download the software and you you go to
town with it yourself so clubs or
companies or what have you could set up
their own internal social networks with
this uh other
privacy interested people could do
that and
um they had uh quickly achieved a
quickly kept their promise but so great
was the enthusiasm and the rush for this
that they decided to move on and begin
to build what they called a consumer
facing Network
and that of course was more um intensive
labor and more intensive coding and they
actually succeeded in getting that done
too though it was still only an alpha
product it never got past at least with
the founders it never got past an alpha
stage but others began to pick it up and
it soon became one of the most
widely
developed open- source free software
products in the world and
um as the months went
on the tensions began to um grow on
these young guys and they inevitably had
uh friction among them they also did
some pretty crazy things they went to
Kleiner Perkins Coffield which is a big
VC firm in the valley and they they
um which had been hugely supportive of
them at least in words and encouraging
to them and they put up a um
presentation to them in which they asked
for $10
million uh and cler Perkins couldn't
understand what they wanted $10 million
for or what they were going to do with
it and they couldn't really explain it
or how anyone would ever get the money
back
um and
uh so as
the time rolled along their their
difficulties extended
to uh you know running out of money they
had raised this $200,000 they were
paying themselves a modest stipend every
month they're paying for Server time and
developer you know and and various
things of course when you're on
Kickstarter one of the things is that
you you end up promising people things
like t-shirts and little dads and you
know as one of the guys said we should
have gone into the t-shirt business
because they had to get 6,000 t-shirts
out to supporters and
um you know they're these are guys who
can order a pizza they they're not very
good at shipping and handling uh or
ordering t-shirts in 6,000
sizes
so uh they had only really in the end
netted about
$170,000 between the
kickstarter cut and between the payments
for these uh fulfillment things these
the t-shirts and so forth so by the
following summer they had run out or
were close to running out of
money
reputation.com then issued them an
invitation to come in said they wanted
to acquire them
acquire diaspora and bring it into uh
its fold reputation.com if you're
familiar with it is a um uh company that
uh whose founder said well the first
trillion dollars that was made on the
web was made off of our data by
advertisers now the next trillion
dollars we're going to have a piece of
that back he called Data the the oil of
the 21st
century and uh he wasn't sure what he
was going to do with
diaspora any more than diaspora was sure
what they were going to do with $10
million if somebody had given it to them
they just figured but they they declined
the invitation to be U brought in into
reputation.com and given some uh money
for that and they continued
working and
um around November of
um Ilia who uh was this their sort of
charismatic
frontman
um had a
uh um a depressive side and he uh uh
took his life and so the project uh
seemed to collapse at that point of
course I mean was a terrible catastrophe
for IL and his family and everybody who
knew him and uh much less whether there
was going to be a be a diaspora around
after that it was not a big issue for a
while but eventually the the four
survivors
uh or excuse me the three survivors and
other volunteers banded together and
they stood diaspora back
up and they continue to work on it for
another
year in fits and
starts and they moved it over to um a
free software
Foundation where it now
resides
and
as I was uh watching this whole all
these events on Ravel over period of a
couple
years I was struck by the ability
of teenagers guys just out of
college to build things without
tremendous amount of
money uh you know in the early in the
1940s the early computer
scientists
uh uh people like van noyman and
truing who did work on the Manhattan
Project and building early computational
machines they broke the distinction
between numbers that mean things and
numbers that do things as the historian
George Dyson wrote in touring's
Cathedral and our un would never be the
same you don't need factories or tanker
trucks to write code intellect combined
with passion or drive can often outrun
Capital so the sense of possibility that
they
embodied I think we can see in
other things that have happened over the
last uh 10 to 15 years
online uh
uh people perhaps in this room may
remember in
2004 when the browser Wars seemed to
have been completed with a victory by
Internet Explorer over Netscape which
was the Insurgent browser that had a
product called Mosaic and then
Netscape um and uh net sprak Netscape
raised a tremendous tremendous amount of
money and then
through uh tough competition from
Microsoft
uh and some crazy things that Netscape
did and to damage itself that company
essentially started to fold and crumble
it didn't fold excuse me but the the
product of another browser began to
disappear from their
Horizon but a group of people
inside of
Netscape had formed a kind of skunks
work they called it
Mozilla and it the name came from
Mosaic which was the uh kind of
innovative browser that had been
developed by Mark andreason and others
at University of
Illinois Mosaic and
Godzilla they were going to slay
uh uh slay their Godzilla with this
Mosaic thing so they call it Mozilla
it's a convoluted nerdy name what can I
tell you they they uh MOS Mozilla was
part of
Netscape and as Netscape was acquired
and
reacquired this group inside of Netscape
was eventually discharged they were sent
away with uh about a million or two
milon ion dollar worth of seed money and
then they disappeared this was in the
late '90s and
then really unnoticed
by by most of the world I would say
perhaps people in Tech were watching
this but I think very it was came as a
huge
surprise in 2004 in November when the
people from
Mozilla announced
that they had a new browser to
distribute and it was called
Firefox and
Firefox was
built on virtually no money by people
who had left NC Netscape which had all
the money you could ever possibly
want and it quickly became a roaring
roaring success it was built by
volunteers from around the world uh
we're all probably familiar with the
privacy setting on our browsers now
which some people call the porn
setting actually it was developed by a
volunteer working on the Mozilla
firescape project project who lived in
Tron and who was not concerned about he
was concerned about what people might
find on his browser if the authorities
came in and seized his computer
and it
wasn't smut or dirty pictures or what
have you that he was worried about he
was worried about looking at the wrong
kinds of political material something
that would be far more
transgressive Firefox was translated
quickly into 70 languages the group
wanted to hold a a party release parties
on every continent and they had six
continents lined up
and
then they felt well that's about it
that's as Global as we're going to get
and then an email dered from a guy named
Ethan Hicks who was working at the
amonson
um uh Scott station in the South Pole
and he said he was going to
hold a launch party too and his thing
was signed I love the signature on his
email the temperature was minus
66 uh degrees when uh he held or he
announced his plans to hold the Mozilla
launch party
there
so I think uh what diaspora ends up
teaching us uh and it's it within the
tradition of uh people who are fighting
for uh to keep the web open
Democratic a place that uh empowers
individuals
and it's part of this tradition from
which
Firefox Linux and some other great
Innovations have
come diaspora inspired by eban mogan's
warnings more than three years
before Edward Snowden emerged had not
penetrated popular culture it was not a
staple of world Commerce it was not both
verb and noun understood across the
globe like Facebook yet diaspora with
its vision of decentralized private
Communications centered on protecting
the Integrity of human connections
remains one of the most active open
source projects in the
world it has more than 55,000 lines of
code 22 revisions hundreds of contribut
hundreds of
contributors and uh dozens of them who
are still working on it regularly it has
not died it was not
vaporware contrary to what some of the
Skeptics had predicted when they first
raised their
$200
$200,000 the four NYU guys had not spent
the money on Apple teis and hookers its
imaginative Sparks had lit up corners of
the world far from the third floor
computer room at NYU
diaspora had become even more necessary
than when Dan rafy Ilia and Max had
first been gripped by its
possibilities as the project they
created in 2010 moved to a foundation in
2013 Max wrote to the community that was
going to be running it dipra is more
than just code he said it's about a
glimmer of hope that a small group of
people could actually make a profound
change or they could live trying
to so I will be glad to
take questions and discuss diaspora
or anything
else
thank curious about where are the
remaining three
now uh they
are one of them Rafi is in the
Navy Mac is running a company that
essentially does what he wishes someone
had done for diaspora which is fulfill
Kickstarter request for startups it's
apparently quite a good
business and Dan is working as a
software developer in New York
City and um somewhere in here I had a
slide yeah this a this is a a a
uh thing called the uh open huton open
Hub net that
um tracks open-source products and and
uh I took this picture I guess last week
and it says that it still has very high
activity
um so there's others there a mostly
European hackers who are now working on
it are you a M of diaspora I
am I'm also uh someone at talk in New
York last week said are you on Facebook
and I
said I want to point out before I answer
that question that hypocrisy is more
widely practiced than any religion or
Creed on Earth and I am on
Facebook and yes sir are you conscious
about your activities on Facebook now
more than
before well having
uh been married to essentially the pole
rever of uh tracking I I I uh I am
indeed conscious of it uh and more so
than before I'm also conscious of the
incredible value people get out of
connections on the web um you know when
I was a kid growing up I I grew up in in
New York City I was born there and I
lived in uh you know basically regular
neighborhood in Manhattan uh before it
was sort of this Disneyland of money and
and the kids used to play when we were
kids we used to play on the street all
the time and you know the moms would
kind of stick their heads out the window
and look at us once in a while go back
inside and if somebody was getting into
trouble or had an accident or what have
you down in the
street
and your mom wasn't looking out the
window one of the neighbors would be
likely to go and tap on the steam pipe
and the message would go up and down the
building and your mom would know to go
stick her head out the
window
and I've often thought about that
internet um in line with with with
uh the the pleasures I get out of
connecting with people from my old
neighborhood who I had many of whom i'
had lost touch with as uh you know we
all grew into adulthood and uh we sort
of had
a minor Resurrection you might say on on
the Facebook page after having met in
person I think one of the most
interesting things about Facebook is how
it
grew uh and it's it it emerged as you as
we all probably know the creation myth
of Facebook right Zuckerberg in his
dorm at Harvard with some friends and it
started at Harvard and then I where you
go to Yale next or Stanford next but it
went school by school but what it did
was it moved from Real World
networks I'm in Spanish class and I want
to know about the cute girl over there
or I'm in bio class and I want to know
about that cute guy over there or
whatever I'm just curious about someone
I see at
school you could do at on Facebook right
it was an it was an adjunct to a real
world
Network and its success I think was that
it emerged from the template of real
life uh and the networks that we have in
real life uh and I think the failures
or um let's say The Limited success that
has been had by uh diaspora other would
be social networks is that they don't
have organic networks that are part of
their DNA they have
aspirations I'm into privacy I want to
be against Facebook but that's not the
same connection as the kid I used to
play tag with on 95th Street or my
friend from work who's now moved on to
another job those are different kinds of
connections than some of these um um
other emerging social networks can offer
last month we sorry go yes Amy um an
online question any thoughts about
tracking and potential connections being
made by government such as the NSA
government agencies such as the
NSA you know if you have a chance and
can go look at a you well I don't know
if it's on YouTube but the C video is
online of this this talk by eban mowan
which inspired these guys we call it
freedom in the
cloud and mowan talked in
2010 about
virtually every single thing that Edward
Snowden revealed to us in
2013 about the interrelationship between
the commercial surveillance economy and
the ability of totalitarian and non-
totalitarian regimes to monitor us there
that industry that industrial
strength Data Mining and so forth has
has been a very very important part of
uh government surveillance expansion and
uh there's a story in the book
about when I started on this project it
was right before the uh the Arab Spring
and I and
I met a whole bunch of people from Syria
and Egypt and Tunisia and Thailand's
other places where there was going to be
a it turned out there was a lot of
upheaval and they were very much you
know concerned about the double-edged
sword of being online right about how it
was this enormously powerful tool for
communications and I remember that
Thanksgiving in
2010 there was a um a Facebook page in
Egypt that was devoted to the name of a
young man who had uh been uh killed
while in police custody and it had
become a rallying point for the
opposition to the mabarak
regime and there was an election going
to be held uh what was our Thanksgiving
weekend I'm not sure what the
significance of the date is in in Egypt
but
every election year they they have uh
polling at that at that time of year and
there was actually a single candidate
being put up as authentic
opposition
and Facebook struck down the page three
days
before the election now
they I I believe that in being in a big
organization where things often stupid
things often seem to happen for sinister
reasons but they're really stupid I
think that probably was a stupid thing
but
you know Facebook does have enormous
power over
our Communications as we become more and
more dependent on it um there's a
there's also one of the people I spoke
to for for this was a young Iranian man
whose father was the
um spokesman for an opposition
presidential candidate in I think 2009
in
Iran and his father had been very
conscious
of avoiding surveillance there was a
very intense surveillance
force uh in regime in place by the
security regime and and he
um yet he was trailed up to a remote
village where he had been essentially
kind of living in
cognito and found and arrested and
brought out for sedition or something
like that and beaten to a and put in
prison where I think he still is now six
five six years later and what had
happened was the father had used his
noia
phone um to communicate with foreign
journalists during this
campaign and noia had sold an entire
Suite
of
products to governments that enabled a
very powerful tracking
capability they got haed before the
European Union's uh committee on on I
guess privacy or civil liberties or
something like that how can you do this
what well and and noia said look we're
really sorry we didn't you know we
regret this and we're going to be okay
but they said just want you to know
every single one of the governments
represented at this hearing Western
Europe every single one of you guys put
it in your specifications when you
ordered these systems that you wanted
this
ability so it's a uh it's a vexing
problem I I I
uh
uh but I don't think it's an unsolvable
problem I don't think anything's
unsolvable right because I think you you
have smart people like the people in
this room and smart kids like these guys
down in myu I think you you can almost
solve anything you can you can fix stuff
uh you you can uh one of the great
things moglin said was that you know the
beginning of the 20th century the
countries that were the most powerful
had the the most steel the best steel
they said well now it's going to be the
countries that have the best math that
are going to be the most powerful and I
I think that uh the truth is we are
still in the Big Bang
moment of the digital era and the atoms
have not yet settled into their final
shape and
and the forces that are driving them we
can't even map them out yet but you're
all part of it and
um so that so I'm I'm you know whoever
asked that question online about yeah I
think it's a big deal U this capability
and and I think uh it's a big
responsibility for everybody who has the
abilities that you guys have because a
lot of folks are just going to swipe and
get on their mobile phone and be online
and make themselves very vulnerable in
ways that they don't know about maybe
it's not such a big deal in this country
but there's a lot of places in the world
where it is a big
deal thank you so much thank
you